how much do you want to separate the art
from the artist
that's where we're starting today okay
just with an easy just a softball to
kick us off right let's do it i don't
know the answer to this question and i
don't know where i because like look if
you if you wanted to
how far back do you want to go in which
artist because there was some
most artists
most artists are [ __ ] up
like
look you look at writers you look at
musicians
they
and i feel that it is that was weird at
least call out game directors
game directors and
you know not actors actors are actually
typically all very powerless horrible
people
famously yes famously completely
balanced for the record i wasn't going
to contest this
i do but i mean those are typically the
two people
like charles bukowski right
pretty troubled dude hemingway super
troubled um you can go to poe uh emily
dickinson like you can name a bunch of
of world famous writers that are
household names that weren't like yeah
they're pretty upbeat you know
normal mine ran normal person ein rand
famously a very chill person super chill
well-rounded
no extreme views
i think stephen king is one of the few
that's kind of like
okay that dude admitted that if he
weren't writing books about [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that he thought he would be a
serial killer
he was like i think i write about it so
i don't do it yeah
cool i mean you do a little bit more
research by the way his work is amazing
have you read you've read you must have
read stephen king on writing on writing
yes and i find a little bit of it very
frustrating because there are
possibilities that are just right dude
yeah yeah well okay stephen king but yes
i have read it
yeah yeah on writing is great unwriting
is one of the go-to's that i have
that that that accomplished writers
laugh at me for they're like don't stop
reading that [ __ ] i'm like no it's
not done it's not [ __ ] you you've
had an education i haven't and that's
that's my thing is i'm always playing
from behind like that'd be a better
right than stephen king to call that
book my generally [ __ ] advice on
reading books about writing or anything
else if you want to be a writer is to
read everything including things that
are bad
absolutely just read more
it's all bits and pieces here and there
right yeah sure and it's also like if it
applies to you if it helps you it's
useful then great if not throw it away
and find something else but even if it's
not then you can think about why you
didn't find it useful and how it is
compatible with your skills so it's
still useful to you there's never an
excuse and i'm saying this is from
someone who who
pales in comparison my my level of
academia and education compared to
everybody else who's on the screen is
way below everyone else's
absolutely and arguably
but
i believe that you cannot try to excel
at anything and education should never
be something that i
try to stave off i i had a friend who
was a writer i was like i don't know man
i just kind of like like i like my raw
vibe and i i like the way that i just
kind of naturally do this and i'm afraid
that if i got into the system that i
would just be programmed to write a
certain way i was like well then you're
not capable of
you're just blown by every women wave as
opposed to like so many composers that
say the same thing i don't really want
to learn because i'm gonna undermine
my natural instincts i'm like that's
like saying
i don't want to broaden my vocabulary
because yeah the words that i am using
are already so perfect yeah that i
couldn't possibly
it's a hit
it's a big basically it's basically it's
basically
there is a very small percentage of
people who are born you know geniuses
and don't need to educate themselves and
will be the best of their generation but
the odds are it's not you right i don't
think people
i i would agree with alana i'm pointing
to alana i also think that i think
that's true you said you don't think
geniuses need to educate themselves i
don't think there's ever been a genius
who didn't i'm saying that there are
like once in a generation people who i
think brilliant and genius i think jesus
is one foster i think they still need to
educate themselves and if they're
geniuses they would well my point is
none of us are geniuses so we all have
to go and educate well all right well
yeah
especially those writers just musicians
am i right why why does alana's mike arm
look such like an affront right now it's
just like
for sure yeah dude it's [ __ ] power
moving it is powerful yeah yeah bottom
line read
yeah re read specifically like
there's a lot reading is i really don't
think that people read that much anymore
and i i there's there's a lot of studies
that i was listening to this dude um
from daley stoic if you're not hit to
him he's really really cool he's talking
about specifically the um
the practice of reading and the practice
of literally writing not this but
writing
is something that is
it's crucial to
neuroplasticity it's it's crucial to
just us as as people we've been doing it
for so long and there's there's
mechanics that our brain uses and our
eyes use only on those two activities
that if you just were to listen to stuff
it's not good so i'm i'm a big fan of
podcasts but i also still start my day
every morning by reading for that simple
fact i just don't want to go i'm trying
to stay as as i'm not afraid of it
necessarily as much as mike is a death
but i do want to do everything that i
can to not have
fuzzy brain when i'm uh you know 70.
yeah it totally helps with that too
there are there are two things that i've
done since uh joining santa wanting
studio one is i buy any book that
anybody at the studio ever offhandedly
mentions i don't go to people and say
hey can you recommend me some books just
anytime anybody mentions a book i
immediately buy it and so i have this
stack of books that like and some of
them are bad because they were talking
about them negatively but i buy all of
them it's a good way to get books that
i've never even heard of some that are
very good some that are like
specifically about game design there are
tons of them um and the second one is
all of the notes that i take
uh unless i need them to be
for everyone else i take all of my notes
by hand like all of my endnote books
written down because it i feel like it
just helps me remember i'm getting into
that as well
i i i just saw the early composition of
jerusalem yeah i'd get fired if i showed
my notes austin so yeah i'm banking on
it being indecipherable and i covered
um but yeah i have i i i'm very much the
same i like having a
physical my my desk here is also covered
in sticky notes that are an extension of
the same thing um where i uh
there's that is definitely a thing
um
i i write like i was literally just
writing and i um
put
i i will do it with my ipad like uh
especially like writing lyrics or ideas
or stuff like that i will i will i will
punt to typing as opposed to writing
um
for no other reason
i think i'm faster yeah and
with with that um
i don't know i don't know why it also
transfers across devices so if i
i'm not as skilled of a writer um so a
lot of times if i have the idea i must
get it down in some tangible form
immediately
but that's a practice for me too because
i'll be like i'll i'll get back to that
and i'll lose the idea
and there's some people that i think
have better retention so
just do voice memos rather than writing
things down you should see mine it's
it's the same
yes i have i have voice memos
my voice memos is probably my most used
app next to like email same
really i guess it makes sense both of
you you are the listen i'll sit at the
piano and make a 30 minute
audio file of like playing with some you
know even if it's like four notes just
trying different permutations
and then like 27 minutes then i'll be
like that was that was it that was it
right there and then because i because
it actually was it
i actually don't need the memo at that
point
um but there's every now and again
i'll be like [ __ ] i remember there was
something in there
that and i'll have to go and sit there
and go through the absolutely
painful process of listening back to one
of those do you title it or do you leave
it just as like the generic recording no
no i do i do title them because i i then
immediately save them into the correct
project folder i'm pretty anal about the
organization aspect of it
um
and but this was also how um how i wrote
these songs with tripod for we did
almost everything as audio pass passing
forward back and forth with um on on
stray gods it's like postal service man
literally yeah literally did i say
that's so weird do you guys hear that
yeah postal service it's like postal
service
i'm still learning all of my audio
recordings are
um
auditions
and
i have one in here for some reason
that's four seconds that's called alana
v austin
oh [ __ ] let's play that i don't remember
this uh showdown you can always cut it
out let's play it
[ __ ] you austin yeah it's like events
location
oh that that was a pickup um undisclosed
location for [ __ ] sake austin i had
picked up for what uh i had to you said
something was in a certain location and
you were like can we cut that and it was
too weird for me to cut it so i had to
add in undisclosed location over the top
of everything
because like funny
but i like how you framed that as
versus me a lot of the austin it does
say
yeah i was ruining everything i do like
that the i the iphone who you might be
familiar with hop out of it
um
does this now like almost like geo tags
your your voice memos i don't know if
the android does as well
so like yeah this will like be
on my home address or it'll be like hey
you're on the 101
um or this was on you know the 405 or
whatever and it also gives you the date
so like mine most of mine would have
been there for like yes on the 405 or on
the 101
piano yeah dude this is so much fun this
is
from my earliest one is may 21st of
2016.
that makes me sad because i'm sure
there's earlier ones than that but it's
like early versions of songs here's me
walking through st patrick's uh st
patrick's cathedral and hearing a choir
just like oh man these are great
i definitely have been in hotel rooms um
following meetings like doing an
off-site fly to another city i had this
specifically happened once
where they i flew to uh to a company out
of the country we had our meeting and
they said you know all right well when
you get back to your studio let's start
working on like a theme you know just a
simple
melody
so i have a little uh piano app that
troy has had to hear many times recently
um
that's just like standard like it's like
a casio you know
like it's just a very simple little
um
piano you know on the on the thing and
of course it's really hard to play
accurately because there's no
yeah you've got like a total of like 17
keys yeah so like if you jump up an
octave austin's like so your notes are
right we're about to record doing dude
it's really difficult to play this thing
with any kind of accuracy because you
rely on feeling the physical placement
difference between the black and the
white keys to know where you are and
here it's just a flat screen of a phone
so i have absolutely no orientation you
just have to look at it right but even
then it's so if i'm off by a pixel i hit
the wrong key you know like whereas so
anyway point being um
i was in this hotel room and i was like
i have this idea for theme and i want to
iterate on it and so i started recording
the memo app in the background while
playing this
like you know do that
yeah it'll record and but then what's
funny is it's it's recording the
microphone hearing this coming out of
the speaker it's not like an internal
recording of the of the uh audio the
result of which is that it was loud as
[ __ ] it was so it's like i think i have
this and i'm like talking over it with
no perception so in the it's just
this absolutely painful thing to listen
to because it's just this you know
like insanely loud horrible of course
that won't come through because this
here we'll do a second one for the oh it
came true it came through
you know it sounded the same volume at
both of them bizarrely can i listen to
the first one again just
the zoom microphone
lose a little bit of the high end
stephen like are you mike bethel do you
do the voice memo
welcome to the show no
thank you what's your writing process
mike where do you start out
go i think we've been wrong how do you
write go
how do you write
anything wait wait are you writing
yeah flipped around the page no i am
we're all right handed correct dominant
right right hand dominant left foot
though
left footed i'm left footed yeah what
the [ __ ] does that mean my left foot
forward when i board or skateboard or
hygiene like
what what i actually remember that being
the same when i when i uh i haven't
snowboarded in 20 years but when i did i
also led with my left which i remember
being i remember people going that's odd
that you're right and you
yeah right now travelers
and i don't know if that's going to
stick or if like there's some point
where they decide what they're going to
be but he he every time we're like well
looks like he's left-handed he goes [ __ ]
you and he starts using it
anyway mike how do you write how do you
write mike
and also which foot is your dominant
foot what is your dominant fight that's
great i'm right-footed as well i'll take
my answer off the air thank you
[Laughter]
this podcast for me has a completely
different vibe when i record it in the
evening
because i'm very i just like to point
out i'm kind of exhausted and yeah it's
good sunlight sunlight
that we kicked off
with a kind of death of the author we'll
get back to it i'm keeping it in mind
and then now we're like but wait are you
right-handed stop everything i need to
know
more importantly are you left footed
i don't know am i am i right-handed
right fight right-footed i've never yeah
you're right-footed you would know if
you want mike how do you how do you
start out writing
i don't remember this is becoming an
existential thing i'm looking at my feet
i i assume i used to but it's been so
long now um i start i start with uh
paper
for note-taking i start with rock
you start with rock okay scissors for
you austin um
which hand do you hold this is it
um well what are your first notes though
what are you where do you
where do you begin i gotta say this
feels very unnatural
put them down
that's true you'll witness a horrible
mutilation
go on mike oh sorry though i just oh um
i i just i turned 10 star with like big
broad structure stuff but to be honest
most of my like that's when i'm
literally sitting down to like big to
you know break a story or figure
something out you start with plot
you always
the short versions i write like a coder
so i start with structure and and
usually that's plot but but generally
plot through character arc specifically
so like structure from a character
character driven kind of perspective and
then and then figure that through um you
know start with my beat sheets and and
go from there i'm kind of happy
basically i just write it in a very
hacky way um but then in terms of like
my like notes and note taking i'm a
coder so i write in notepad like on the
computer like i've just got pages and
pages at any one time of like what if
you're not around that though like do
you do you hold the ideas in that giant
i love that you think there's any part
of my job where i'm sitting outside in
front of a computer
yeah i live
yeah basically i i'm actually it's
something i'm trying to improve uh and
and make more space for because i i do
have the same thing alarm is describing
where the act of actually writing on a
piece of paper like it it helps my brain
to kind of retain and think it through
so i am getting i'm getting i'm trying
to get one of those um those e-ink
notepads i'm gonna try playing with one
of those for a bit
um because the problem is i just end up
surrounded by post-it notes and bits of
paper so i'm gonna be playing with that
yeah i the thing that keeps me from
doing that is is the uh the i guess i'm
a texture guy more than i thought i was
and
even with the ipad writing on an ipad
um i know people the egg ones have like
texturing now so they feel like a biro
on paper apparently
that's what i've heard um there's a
there's a production shortage in the one
i won at the moment so i'm waiting for
it it seems so strange that we would
spend thousands of dollars on this new
technology to make it feel like the old
technology
that's right that's fair but i don't
know how you are more renewable sources
i end up with 20 notepads all half
filled so i also have sprites so right
now i have a and also accessibility that
troy wants like you can pull that up
from a beach somewhere or from a meeting
in a different country or terrible i
don't keep anything like and i found out
kerry's been keeping a lot of my old
notes and stuff just just because she
knew i'd throw them out otherwise yeah i
keep them all i have a plot notepad and
a character notepad that uh currently i
filled twice and then just here are a
couple of uh binders that i have full
that were all game previews so you can
like see what i thought of mass effect
andromeda the first time i played it
because i also the way that i
take notes is pretty um
i guess direct this level sucks i
[ __ ] hate this game
a little bit better even at work i'm
like this didn't make any [ __ ] sense
to me like i i like absolutely write
down what i'm thinking at the time be
like what the [ __ ] does that mean
question mark and then point to it
remember
i'm trying to remember if you've ever
done a preview of one of my games
because that would be i've never
previewed you
right now
it's going to be a great 200th episode
there's a lot that doesn't dramatically
thomas was alone
i i feel like um
there's there's a lot of shows that
whatever that i watched or or movies or
or what have you
where i
i actually recently just did this with
um walking through
uh vox machina
i was watching that and it's terrific
show if you haven't if you're the same
seven
person or seven p person who hasn't seen
that in the world it's a bad joke don't
worry about it you should watch the show
anyway
um i was like i can't believe they're
doing that it's kind of like all right
this may be the point where i'm a little
disappointed and then they pay that off
and so
i i'm curious especially as like doing
something that's that's review-based or
getting to that level of judgment early
i do this a lot in in in creative um
whether i'm writing or thinking about
something
and a friend of mine wayne miller is a
great producer
musician and songwriter
is the one that kind of instituted this
protocol where it's like don't jump
between the creative roles and there's
the
um there's the madman the architect the
engineer and the judge i think is or
madman the
uh
architect the builder and the judge
sounds like the hbo lineup
right
the the purpose of it is if you have an
idea just be in that idea space and
don't worry about how it's going to
happen don't worry how you're going to
pull it off or don't worry if it's going
to be good or not just get the ideas out
and then once you feel like the ideas
are there then you can move into the
structure you can move into the okay
let's uh let's set this down what does
it look like here are my beat sheets
let's let's pull out stephen king john
writing or whatever and then you
actually write the thing or you record
the thing or you make the thing and then
you can set back and go
all right is this good or bad
it's so fast because i could never work
like
it's that brain it's a brain chemistry
thing maybe because that sounds horrible
to me it's interesting how different
people work
i think it's making sure you don't judge
to jump to judgment too early
that would pertain to game reviews there
was a really interesting thing i don't
keep my game reviews because like those
i did have to publish thus i wrote them
on a google doc or whatever and you
could go through the edit history and i
would generally start writing after like
my first play session and then go
through and change things and those
would significantly evolve from the
start opinions i had to begin with would
be very different when i finished them
do you think there's anything persistent
about that that remained even though you
were like oh i thought they were going
to do this and they ended up that was
way more clever occasionally but that
would depend on the game like i don't i
think most games when you review them
the review you wrote in the first day
will only change a little bit towards
the end you can get a very good idea of
what a game is after five hours
generally um
i'm sure there are games that have done
that but i struggle to think of at least
something like this
okay description is a great example
uh do you feel like people should finish
a game but i'm sorry i was trying to
keep cutting off go ahead well i was
asked if you've read the book blink of
malcolm gladwell he talks about um
how we we in we on board information
essentially instantaneously on our
subconscious level and then and then
sometimes it's sometimes it's really
wrong
and sometimes it's it gets to the truth
of the matter
vastly more quickly than our conscious
thinking it can still be an erroneous
judgment but it's more revelatory of us
like that's
like in a for an example if i see
someone who looks a certain way i have a
fantastic example of this i can get to
later but
uh being able to look at someone and go
i have a judgment about that person
that could be a wrong judgment but it's
still as reflective of who you are
yeah it's not it's not arbitrary
information there's something that's
driving it in and if you can learn to
kind of really listen to those inner
instincts you can kind of speed up the
process of getting your subconscious and
your conscious mind sort of
uh aligned with each other and he uses a
million interesting case studies in the
book of people who had a snap judgment
and then it took quite a bit of due
diligence to figure out how they even
knew what they knew and
two of my favorites there's one where
they give people a game where they put
uh like a stack of i'm i might be
slightly fuzzying some of the details
but it was more or less a study where
they put a deck of red cards and blue
cards where
um below each like on the other side of
them were numbers of positive or
negative and it was like okay you have
five minutes you can draw from either
deck and your goal
you know add the numbers together and
your goal is to get the highest possible
total number and
what they discovered was one deck had a
very had it's very slow rising average
and the other one was very volatile so
you would draw like 50 and think oh wow
that was a big number and then it would
draw like negative 75 and it would set
you way back and so after maybe
30
draws or something like that
people realized okay if i if the goal is
to get the highest possible number stick
with the slow and steady deck and they
could figure that out relatively quickly
what was interesting is they hooked them
up to
like sensors measuring skin temperature
and if their palms were sweating and
their heart rate and that kind of thing
and they would start to show signs of
anxiety within three draws on the
volatile deck like their palms would get
sweaty and their their skin temperature
would rise and things their body
essentially was internalizing the idea i
can already pin this as a suspect way to
win this game but their brain hadn't
consciously formed that thought until
many draws later but to the review one
the other case study was they
did one where they uh
they they took a survey of students at
the start of a semester in university
and said rate your professor
based on your anticipation of your
appreciation of this class
and then like after after like the first
you know
day or whatever and then they would
take that measurement against their
review of that professor from the final
day of the semester and find that
the 90 or some extremely high numbers
reviews didn't change and so then they
kept going further and further with it
saying okay let's take the reviews after
the first hour after the first minute
and they got it all the way down to
it was like a second or five seconds of
audio that had been eq'd to completely
obscure the actual words all you heard
was the tone of voice
and they still got nearly the same
review as they did why we spent so much
time play testing the first hour of a
video game everyone like that's we you
first impressions matter and it's what
it's what it's what creates that
foundation people will forgive you for
terrible game development and game
design later down the line if you can
nail that first hour it's interesting
what you said about um about the the
card game and the sweaty palms it
reminds me i'm gonna have to be very
vague but i'm currently i'm giving like
playtest feedback on someone else's game
at the moment and it's very new it's
very numbers based games very
complicated maths um and i'm almost
deliberately just as like a test case
i'm playing it stupidly like i'm
basically playing it on gut feel and
what's really interesting is that that
works and it kind of i can intuitively
completely abstract it's nothing to do
with any real world experience i would
have it was really interesting talking
to the designer about it because
basically
it it demonstrates how well balanced the
system it is that it's learnable in that
way that you can
feel your subconscious solvent
that's his success as a designer that's
not mine as a player but it feels great
as a player to kind of have that and
that's it's a really interesting all of
these things come up when you're doing
like play testing and and design process
because
you know it's you're so much dealing
with someone's subconscious as much as
you are they're conscious that's why
it's why we spend that's why it's like
naughty dog do so much with like
recording players as they're playing and
stuff just because the things they tell
you will have
will be ten percent of what you actually
need from them in terms of feedback are
you saying on that game that the game
was responding to how you played or
you're saying that it was enjoyable on
multiple levels i was saying i was
saying that the underlying maths i'm i'm
sorry i'm intentionally like making it
up but the underlying kind of systems
and maths mean that
in the same way as you have a gut feel
for like
how much petrol you need to put in your
car
um
it's the same thing of like once you've
been playing with those systems a bit
you get an intuitive sense of like okay
i've got i can do about this or the game
is giving me these affordances um and
it's and that's that that's a good
system basically if a game system can
intuitively get you there which which is
true of like most games most players
when you're playing like you know
playing halo or something you know hour
four you're not making conscious
exclusively conscious choices the player
is not going i need to shoot that guy so
i'm gonna go and get it's all automatic
it's that learned it's rocking um which
uh another book theory of fun which
again is like a very entry level design
book that everyone should read but like
the that book deals exclusively
specifically with rocking did you see a
lot of you already own that book or were
you doing it for you
yeah i said it it's like it's honestly
it's it's it's like saying hey just down
there
this way you guys you guys the yellow
one i think queen they're really good um
like it's it's yeah it's it's a good
syrian fun for game design yeah ralph
koster
who's very clever fellow um
but yeah grok king as a concept the idea
basically the idea of like you don't
consciously think about brushing your
teeth because you've just internalized
that skill set every day and games game
good game design good game design plays
with that and uses that and that's why
that's why games can feel transcendent
and like experiences rather than just
data entry
an interesting thing about the way that
people talk about
hard games like the way people talk
about elden ring
in a way that's anti-accessibility they
talk about you know it's meant to be
hard
yeah but
they there's no world in which they
didn't play test that game to give you
the exact experience that you're having
they yes the game's supposed to be hard
but it's also
very specifically designed for you to be
able to finish it as is everything and
specifically you to finish it yeah like
that's the other thing with peach which
people don't realize with play testing
music i think cuphead was designed for
me to finish it
but like from like play testing like
something like
it's not that they play tested we don't
play test games with generalized human
audience we play test it with like a
segment we go okay who's the like for
example with like john wick we
specifically we play tested with john
wick fans who weren't into games and
strategy gamers and we kind of use those
two sets to kind of balance and figure
things out a lot because we were like
these are people these are the people
who are likely to want to play this game
um and the same is going to be true of
eldering but where that intersects with
the accessibility thing is if you're not
play testing with players who have those
limitations on their you know abilities
with the game or all those kind of
barriers then you're gonna miss stuff
and it's so it's interesting watching
you're almost getting a new kind of
subset of play testing starting to come
up which is play testing with a minor
accessibility which is a much broader
range accessibility play testing is an
enormous thing now that's right but it's
challenging because you can't just
recruit like with regular play testing
you can just honestly recruit a bunch of
like
quote-unquote gamers and they're very
easy to find that audience and offer
them you know completely you have to
look for specialists for example you
have to specialize on both the play
testers need to be specialists and then
of course the people you're play testing
with need to specifically need those
accessibility features so it's a it's a
fascinating kind of emerging field okay
so
i remember a producer telling me one
time in the studio like turn off the
radio because if you're writing right
now you are automatically listening to
the past and you will in whether
consciously or subconsciously you will
emulate what you're hearing and it'll
start sounding like that song and you'll
start singing like that person you'll
just naturally do that
so
as as a as a game maker
um i'm curious with everybody
you mike having that being privy to that
information seeing the play test you can
are you saying you can kind of start
going i know who's going to finish my
game i know who i'm making this game for
and then do you start sub question do
you start
either consciously or subconsciously do
you steer into designing for that person
who is going to finish or do you have to
make sure that you
put some stop gaps so you don't just
intentionally make it for that person
you you create well i think i think all
design requires an understanding of an
audience
all design is about you're actively
targeting someone you can keep it right
but i have to answer the
door stay back
you guys will find this pound yeah we'll
be good um
but yeah you're you're always designing
for a bit alarm yeah
and the design design changes as you go
through the process i would say you've
always got a goal in mind of who you're
making a game for and then you basically
over the course of game development try
and make that game better for that
audience that would be great expectation
or you you're different well i'm trying
to think of what i can say um
[Music]
i would think you're gonna be aiming for
like four pillars with a with you you're
more you're more i'm not getting that in
depth i i was gonna say i think that
i suspect that some uh aaa play testing
is broader than what you are saying
whoever the [ __ ] um
in some cases to just have as many
people play test as possible but then i
would also imagine that aaa can have the
budget for a lot more people to play
test there and triple a needs to do that
because triple a needs to go after that
broader audience if if if i was for
example working
on first parties
hypothetically for a popular games
console yeah you better make a game that
appeals to as big an audience as
possible because that's the audience who
you need to buy playstations you know
i'm not i'm not that's not my audience
i'm for an indie that can actually be
death i'd say some of the weaker
decisions i've made game design wise
over the years have been trying to make
a game that's quote unquote for everyone
um that that's that's separate to the
accessibility conversation all games
should be accessible to everyone but
games don't need to be for everyone in
terms of like the tastes of the
individual if that makes sense i get the
impression from
people that
i talked to
uh in aaa that
the scale is so big that for the most
part you just want to make something
that you and your team think is good so
it's hard to think of
which player is going to like this who
is the audience and why and i'm sure
there are people who do do that and
marketing divisions are dedicated to
that but i feel like that would make me
feel like i was drowning um
my approach tends to be i just want us
in this room to think that the thing
that has been assigned to us in this
room is good collectively with all of
our different experiences and tastes
rather than yeah who is the audience for
this because ninety percent
that's the mode you're in like in terms
of like when i'm talking to my team we
are conscious of that and ultimately
it's my job to cut as director to kind
of have that in the back of my mind but
i wouldn't we don't we don't bring that
that audience up every time we're having
a design meeting it's more yeah it's
we're making what's good you're fighting
you're fighting for the troops next to
you right you're kind of building the
thing yeah
yeah there it is but it is absolutely
something i have i have to personally
kind of have in mind that i'm not
drifting too far away but also a lot of
the time it's reactive i've seen
marketing teams do you think it benefits
you to try to keep it smaller though
like i would think that it does benefit
you to
create for a niche where you don't i
think being specific
i think if anything it just gives focus
and i think as well within the
you don't need you don't need to sell
to everyone in the indie space you just
need to sell to lots of people
um
in a specific yeah in a specific niche i
think and i think of the opportunities
often in india are to go oh that
audience isn't being served you know the
one i i keep going back to is the mini
me guys of um who did um who did like
desperado's three yeah and um and shadow
tactics is like yeah they're great and
if you're like me and you're obsessed
with commandos as a teenager
you've not had a game like that for
decades and now
boom there it is so now i i think that
makes sense what i was also going to say
is it can also be reactive like you
don't necessarily there's definitely
projects where
they've made the game and then realize
who their audience is later and then the
marketing department's kind of figured
out the
the
setup yeah like you sometimes find that
i remember maybe or or specifically i
think i've mentioned this on the show
before but like specifically like what
the what the focus should be i remember
hearing about um and it's shane troy's
not here um the the first shadow of war
game like they didn't know what the
nemesis system was going to be a thing
until they started doing like test
reviews basically and suddenly that's
the thing where it's like okay
i don't know this is this is the story
i've heard i don't know if it's true but
like basically like yeah it was it was a
cool system in the game but you know in
terms of like the massive focus that he
got during marketing that was very
reactive to them doing test reviews and
going oh this is the innovation this is
this is the thing like
because the rest of the game is is good
but it's like it's you know it's a
third-person action open world game like
it's something people have played but
yeah so sometimes that can be found as
well but no i think i think i think i
think
artists make for themselves designers
make for a specific audience that's
that's kind of that was how i was
trained at least that was the kind of
it's maybe a limiting perspective but
that's how i think
i think um i just feel like people uh
underestimate the importance of play
testing across the border like how
seriously studios take it um because
again my thing with with elden ring is
like
people see that as a badge of honor if
they finished it like it's for some
elite group
but
the fundamentally all games are designed
for you to be able to finish them and so
much time and effort goes into making
sure you can finish them from the start
it's let's make a game so people can
finish it i think
yeah but we're not necessarily finished
but that you like it enough that you
tell someone to buy it like sure that
you are entertained by yeah i mean
owning is hard to finish it's so [ __ ]
long i doubt that many people finished
it overall but i just
yeah the the effort is so interesting
really that's awesome it's insane she
she her her gaming consumption is so
haphazard she'll like get obsessed with
the game for a week and then move on and
then not play a game for six months like
any games you know she'll just she'll
just
you know she she spends
problem is it's very you can't really
multitask playing games with being a
visual artist obviously like it's you
you need your hands so she'll end up
watching movies and tv uh if she wants
to multitask otherwise she'll just focus
on painting
but this has become because of the
multi-player component of eldon ring and
she's got some friends back in costa
rica who really love to to party up and
go you know
do [ __ ] and in their case they're
they're higher level than her so they
love taking her to like
to stuff she hadn't found but i was she
was showing me like she she's very she's
only got i think a couple bosses left in
the whole thing she she was
you know
substantially high level and i was like
how many hours of
like i get i gather i've been i i grant
rather i've been pretty busy lately and
getting home sort of late and
and so she's moved on
so kind of it's so funny it's like uh i
think
her thing said it was like 120 hours or
something let's just put in the game
i haven't finished it and yeah she's
like level 150
or something her character which
apparently i was you know i was like
what even is the level cap apparently
it's
the um salsa community does an
interesting thing with every release
where the community decides on what the
level cap should be and tries not to
level above it because that way you can
make sure that you are able to
multiplayer with as many people as
possible because you have to be in a
level range so i believe what they've
decided for eldering is that you should
be around 150 um so that you can still
play with new players all the time and
or as many it's so interesting how that
that game
leaves a lot of the design up to the
audience like fascinating with multiple
if it's good or bad it's interesting
though it's really interesting with
multiple people i have
jumped into
their elden ring game
because i heard about whatever build
they have just specifically to lead them
to a certain area to get them a weapon
or an armor set and then i leave like
i've done that like i'm just like let me
be your guide and just take you to this
thing so you don't have to uncover the
map we don't have to like deal with the
ruined surprises but you need this [ __ ]
at the start of the game one thing i've
done with probably seven people it's
really fun though
being a guide but i haven't finished it
i just paid a lot of attention to all
the starting that was the emergent
social media that that happened in
journey that i don't think anyone
expected is that all the white robed
people would go specifically just to
help to look for because there your robe
has no
um if you're if you're firing up a new
account
your robe is literally just like pure
red there's no even kind of symbols or
anything
and so the white cloaked characters can
see the difference between somebody who
just hasn't found everything versus
someone that has done nothing and it
became like in the year or two after the
game especially when the community was
at its most
populated that people were
it became like this badge of honor of
sorts for
the sort of the white cloak folks to
look for the most new players possible
to show them around if there aren't
multiple people online for journey right
now
and you just play it by yourself and
nobody comes to help you would that slot
get filled by an ai or something or
would it just you just wouldn't have
helped nope no but there's never played
that way there's never there would never
probably would there ever be a moment
you've shown me an experienced journey
on your own that surprised me i thought
that game was still probably quite
populated i mean we just did journey
live in concert like two or three weeks
ago and in our and we did two shows
um like a morning show and an evening
show or like a matinee rather than an
evening and then a a sound check in the
morning and a full rehearsal the night
before and every one of those instances
are you have an account connected to
somebody wow ipad
that's that's where that's
yeah i have no idea what the ecosystem
is like on ios i don't know
no multiplayer there was no it was it
was a completely solipsistic does that
make the game feel really different
yeah well
different a totally different experience
well not to mention the fact that i can
tell you that the music is can the
interactive music systems are connected
to the multiplayer so you will not hear
the full score if you're 100 wow
or a lot of the full score but but kind
of more the intention of the score
because
each permutation is based upon what is
procedurally generated by a player's
game huh can we go yeah can we go back
to the linux i was there i think was a
really good point you were making that
that maybe the audience wouldn't be
aware of but this basically the idea of
all
these other people listening i'm sure
still probably six um but it
is stuff
game design is about affordances which
is i think what you were saying the kind
of the idea that there's no game that's
not made
with an audience in mind completely like
if we made a game yeah that was actually
you know hardcore you know hyper
difficult no one would complete it so by
definition all games they all have to
you can have the hardest game possible
then we walked back so that somebody can
finish it
yeah so it's like so yeah so i've never
really understood the whole kind of
being smug about completing a game it's
quite competitive worked really hard to
make sure that someone could finish it
you know my question was specific to
reviews do you feel that
um
i know what you're gonna ask
do you have to finish it do you have to
finish it to give a review yes i know
that uh i believe so yes uh
with with some exceptions so um elden
ring would be an exception uh i think
that most reviews there is no proper
finish
no because it's impossible um like so
most most reviewers like played it for
170 hours to make sure they understood
most of the content and only had two
weeks to write the reviews so getting
that done is like virtually impossible i
i never reviewed a game that i hadn't
finished personally i i you don't often
hear me um
you know waxing loquacious for epithelia
for for reviewers
um
it's it's not it's it's not a standard
i'm not effusive in my in my empathy for
but i will absolutely concede
that the pressures that are put upon
people in that position
uh who are willfully in that position
right but that this is what they want to
do and i i respect that i truly do are
are doing so under the the premise of
you have two weeks to do this
and
they're fighting a two-front battle
because let's say that that review code
or that that um uh
the build that was given for the
purposes of reviews got to them a little
bit later and then that they know that
everybody else is going to have a
deadline or is going to have their
review out
immediately when that embargo is lifted
not even personal it's your editor will
say this has to be done by this date
yeah but it's a lot of times it's not
even being driven by one external factor
it's being driven by seven and the
public
obviously because that's the grand thing
is the public wants to know and who
whoever gets there first typically will
be
the one who gets to break it
sure so the fact that
and that's that game
that's not the seven other that are
coming out interviewed plenty of games i
didn't want to review that i was
assigned and had to read because it was
my job so i didn't have a choice
probably more often than not would you
say you crunched
yeah
journalists crunch all the time all the
time november is it nightmare do you
feel that needs to change is that is
that being addressed no because i think
i've probably spoken about on the show
before nobody cares when it's
journalists like people like shut up
for a living but like
yeah i got pneumonia because i worked
myself sick and then went to ces and
worked another four days on a weekend
and i've got no days off and just yes
[ __ ] as well right right yeah
yesterday oh no ces
oh i thought i went to go see yes no i
was like why would you go see everyone
hates you like you get you get harassed
for like that was the weirdest thing
about doing that job professionally was
when i knew that i didn't like something
and that everyone wanted me to like it
and that i had to be the person to say
this thing
isn't good um and the harassment that i
would get from that and every time i'd
be like people are gonna be so [ __ ]
mad at me but i have to say what i think
so
that was the worst part that i've never
experienced in any other job is knowing
you're going to be harassed before
something even goes live i do
[Music]
that's fun
do i i i think we say this often but
anyone in position of of anything
really
uh everyone is self-employed everyone is
is
you nobody knows your limits this goes
for actors specifically nobody knows
what is vocally stressful for you
and
i've never worked with someone who like
you're gonna scream until you know blood
comes out of your throat i've done
plenty of sessions where that was the
result
but that's on me that's on me to go i
want to stop i need to stop because
nobody wants it to be bad
nobody wants it to be bad
but
with respect like
that's not
in in in like a qa department aaa studio
100 they're being told to test the game
until their nosebleeds like 100 they
can't stop that's not your experience as
an actor but like in terms of qa in
terms of dev teams like i have been
taken to one side and told by a bosses
if you leave before 9pm every night this
week
you are showing a lack of passion and
you're not going to get promoted like
what you're not part of the family mike
you're not part of the family so like i
think like
personal responsibility is important for
sure but like no if you if you if
you there are every every worker in the
games industry is being
uh told that they have to do these
things otherwise they won't proceed like
in their careers for sure i've never
been in that position i can't speak to
it with with that level of uh experience
all i can say is
you have a choice and the choice maybe
don't work in games but that is your
choice um and and until the industry
changes that may be a reality for some
people what i do like though
is that because of conversations like
this i have seen
be it incremental sometimes change
within the industry to where the big aaa
studios are going we're shifting our
culture in order to do this
and they're feeling the growing pains of
that
but my concern is largely aaa shifting
that culture out of the us but they're
still doing it you can see a lot of
interesting kind of reports coming out
of emerging games industry hotspots in
like asia in particular
um where outsourcing is becoming you
know is where people are being crunched
in that way well you'll often see like
there is there's i'm definitely not in
the mood to name names but there are
triple a studios who proudly proclaim
that they're getting rid of crunch or
they're going to four day weeks or
they're doing whatever but they're still
using outsourcers who crunch asian game
developers just ones without twitter
accounts that are read by american press
so it's i worry that i worry that while
the culture's shifting it's shifting
overseas like it's not sorry a bit
negative maybe no i i just i would i
would couple without this again i'm not
i'm also not sure how i feel about
it being a choice in that the way that i
feel like that absolves the abuses like
i don't think it absolves anything but
it also doesn't deny the fact that
there's a choice i mean yes
to an extent right like when i worked at
ign and i was crunching partly that was
my own fault sometimes i wanted to
but also they owned my visa so if the
choice was don't work in games it's
lose my job leave the country with
absolutely no money uh probably like be
homeless while i try to save to get a
flight back home to australia with all
my stuff somehow terrible technically a
choice
but what's the choice it's a choice
really choice it's not is it a viable
one i'm not saying it's not a viable one
but i think that also
by by and large we could agree that you
had a very very
unique case
well i mean all americans have health
insurance right like
yeah you have to lose that if you're
unwell i don't know yes it's a choice
but it's right
because
it's a scary choice it's that it's uh
it's um one that could be to your
detriment it's not just we'll get a new
job i feel like it's it's just more
complicated than that so is the answer
for someone to not have any personal
responsibility no of course not it's do
not work in the games industry
no that's not true i love what it is i i
i think it seemed to me that the way to
address this because i'm i'm i
definitely come from a similar place
where
where your question implies troy of
i i to me it always feels infantilizing
to
to
uh make it seem like the
the person
you know facing the crunch and whatnot
has no agency in the situation but i
recognize that everything that else is
being said here is also true
that sometimes those choices resemble a
kind of nuclear option that feel like
well that that didn't feel like a hell
of a choice
even though
it's like you still you still have that
on the table the thing that i would add
to it
that i think softens that the blow of
that is
um
if that is the state of thi like let's
just assume that
uh change is
inevitable but slow and incremental in
the practices that make that feel like
such a
unfair choice
if we just assume that's the case then
it would seem to me that it's incumbent
on
on
those in the know who care about how
these choices affect people to broadcast
to those
considering joining the industry to know
this will be the choice that you
potentially find yourself facing so that
you're not
you're not alana going i might be
homeless if i decide this isn't worth it
but you're alana before applying for the
visa going
is this a scenario that i'm willing to
deal with because it is a reality i will
be facing yeah today and now i'm saying
that does not mean that the incremental
work to
improve things or whatnot should
therefore be the foot taken off the gas
it's not an issue
this is fresh on my mind because
um
i literally yesterday was i i saw a
tweet from a friend
about um how music schools don't and
alana you responded music schools don't
teach business
to
music students very often and so you get
these people that are basically
graduating with a mountain of debt and
have no clue how to earn an income and
it's like all the musical training in
the universe is essentially
useless if you don't know how to
actually monetize that
and i think it's a massive disservice to
the point that
i
kind of don't really recommend
university education to people anymore
because i'm like most of that education
can be found elsewhere
and and meanwhile it sets you really far
back potentially
so far back not just financially but but
find it but
it's like the opportunity cost
associated with that time combined with
the massive debt you incur combined with
the fact that they have given you no
tools in your personal wherewithal to
to overcome and recoup on that debt and
then actually profit long term means
it's a i'm like i don't understand what
you're getting at this point what what
is the is a piece of paper worth that to
you certainly
in america you're getting the ability to
like go past a certain point in your
career right isn't that still the case
if you're lucky enough to become a
professional composer which obviously is
a limited pool of people but like i've
literally i've not i i've i've
i have been hired
as a composer if you if you add all
of the
uh projects big and small i have like an
excel sheet that i have kept a record of
every job i've ever done and like if
it's one job equals one line so it
doesn't matter if it's a huge project
that takes years or if it was a tv
commercial that took an afternoon
and i all told i've done something like
350 jobs not once has anyone ever asked
me my academic credentials no because
you're austin wintry
i don't i definitely to the extent that
that means anything i definitely wasn't
that for the first 250 of those yeah
hiring processes at either of the
companies that i've been involved in
hiring um it like you'd read their
resume but i don't think anybody asks
about the degree uh i know in the games
industry no probably not
although i was able to get my visa and
that's my green card because i went to
university so for that it's very
important to be able to get into the us
it's very important
but uh for hiring i don't think anyone's
ever been like so how long did you study
for and where and what were your
favorite normal people jobs though in
normal like non-games industry jobs like
i know i don't know americans who've
been
yeah like real jobs you know in the real
world um
specifically why i was talking about
getting a music degree even within the
subset because it's even more
sort of it's even more true for this
slimmer than even the broader
um industry because i imagine there are
some
departments especially like bigger you
know big big aaa
where you know it it's a helpful
screening process for them given a size
of applicants or whatever and so it
probably does pay some kind of dividend
for getting a job like you said a qa
department or whatnot where they they
need a certain
number of people that they can you know
throw at their at their qa needs and
they need to make sure that they're of a
certain minimum level of proficiency and
whatever skills they're looking for and
probably a university degree is going to
be one
decent filter for but i don't just mean
hiring i mean in terms of like promotion
like i know there's several i think
there's companies in the guide in the
comments let me know if i'm talking
nonsense but like i'm pretty sure
there's quite a few games companies that
famously you can't get past a certain
level of management without having a
degree really like still yeah it's a
really old school way of doing it but
i've encountered that i've heard stories
about like people who've people who've
been excellent and it doesn't mean i'm
sure there are ways around it i'm sure
if you work twice as hard you can you
can push past that ceiling but still
like the thing that stands out
regarding a degree in terms of um
hiring processes in game development
is that to me it indicates that somebody
has worked with teams in a way that's
very stressful uh whereas potentially if
you haven't been to university like i
don't care what you studied but you've
probably had to do a group assignment
with a deadline that was hard and you
had to work together to do it that's it
finished and you did agree i remember a
friend of mine his dad was the senior
vice president of a big company and he
was like a degree is all that i look at
and there's a reason why has no idea it
could be a degree in basket weaving i
don't care but you stuck it out for four
years and those are the kind of people
that we want to see higher it's like
totally get it totally understand that
and i think that there are things that
you can show that like me i don't have a
college education i i can demonstrate
to an employer and i have in the past
my stick-to-itiveness and my passion and
my zeal and my self-startedness and
everything that
would that be
if somebody gave me the chance i could
show them the same thing that paper is
supposed to be indicative of right
and some people may not be as like i'm
not going to look at it and there could
be other people that
if you went to stanford and they went to
yale or whatever and they're like i'm
not even going to talk to that person
because there's that old school
mentality
um
my going back to the original point i i
just always find it for me it was really
empowering the original point was death
of the author that was the author alana
was right we're gonna come back to this
yeah um
i find it incredibly empowering for
someone to say just let you know to
austin's point as well you have a choice
here um
and to to realize that you're not uh
i think some people i i felt this way
too i thought that when i walked into
that studio i was at their behest
and if i had someone one time in a
session i do not advise this by the way
because i i had to take the consequences
of this action as well but i had a
director we finished our work
and i looked at the script i was like
guys is there anything else in the the
guy who was kind of like directing for
the studios like that's that's all we
have and we we finished early and he was
like
give me some more stuff
and he was like well we don't have any
more stuff he's like he's not getting
out of that booth until
his time's up i bought the time does it
excuse me composers have done this with
orchestras on sessions before as well he
said hey
i booked you from two to six i got you
from two to six and i went
and i took the headphones off and i
walked out of the booth and walked right
past him into the parking lot i was like
the thing you don't that i think
bothers me with the choice thing is
again technically you're right i just
think that
uh
it requires a lot of privilege i think
that if you were a woman of color and
you were to walk out you'd never work
again because that would spread so fast
that you'd be you're a troublemaker
troublemaker bad to work with
unprofessional whereas on the privileged
side of that you are less likely to be
attacked for doing something like that
and i think that that's probably my
issue with it across the board and you
wouldn't do that your first job troy
would you that's something you did once
you'd
no actually it was something that i was
uh i was earlier today i remember my
first job it was me it was john wick i
remember i remember my first job blue
diamond phillips so i had a pilot for
abc that never got picked up and the
best thing that i got out of that was a
friendship with that dude and
i had just quit smoking and i saw him
outside of his trailer smoking i was
like i want to talk to because i want to
talk about young guns
and i walked out of my trailers like hey
man can i bum smoke he's like sure
and we just got to chatting up and and i
said let me ask you a question man at
what point in your career did you go
stop
i was like i haven't even asked my
question because you're already wrong
because what i hear you asking me is at
what point do you think you will arrive
and the point is you never will if you
believe in something you ask for it from
the jump but you better damn well know
that it's something you really believe
in because it may cost you everything
and that to me is the real thing it's
it's
i can't speak from someone who's a woman
of color i can't i can't speak from that
position
but if nothing else if i'm i'm if i'm
talking to other 46 year old dudes who
are trying to
do what they're passionate about then
i'm fine speaking to that one other
person and i still totally think that
you sharing your perspective is super
super valuable like like you shouldn't
not do that for sure i just think um
like i have two friends specifically who
are both actors who are people of color
who so frequently talk about
she did this and that's super annoying
or this actor did this and that's super
annoying we can't do that the the two
people of color can't do that they're
like nah i know we can't do that they
don't feel like they can speak up for
themselves because they're aware that
their reputations will sink way way way
faster than the white girl on set who
showed up late and cried or the dude who
od'd and didn't get any trouble the they
as people of color are both like no we
have to be perfect or or we will be the
reason
that you shouldn't hire people of color
and i think that is the the thing where
i just take choices like uh it's also
for people who are very underprivileged
who don't have money it's very hard to
leave a job like that that or just folks
starting out right like if you're i did
the same thing i was broke i was broke i
i've dug through my couch and you
probably had jobs you hated that you
didn't quit you technically have a
choice
sure but you didn't have the position to
be able i did have jobs that i hated
that i quit or i did have and i
shouldn't have really i should have
stuck them out yeah of course man i play
i play
i've it's
but i i'm i i will admit that i'm weird
i i was told specifically you can't
pierce your ears and i went and i did it
myself
so i mean i don't think everybody should
have that rebel renegade thing in there
and i'm trying to remember there's a
source for this quote that i wish that i
could remember
um nobody could until somebody did
and
again i can't speak to such a swath of
of different people from different um
backgrounds and and different situations
um but i do know that throughout history
we have we have marked and venerated
those
that when when you're told that you
can't and somebody did
those are the people that we revere and
i'm not saying that you should be that
person or or that there's some
um
i think i do that all the time the
amount of people who are like you can't
work at a triple a game studio and also
have uh several comedy podcasts where
you talk about brothels watch this [ __ ]
legitimately i've had people be like you
can't do both of these things that's not
you i love the way the seriousness is
that you know that's what i like
well no the other the video game writing
101 podcast is very serious that's real
that's real it's very serious it's so
serious than this
have you cried on idiots that abroad
i laugh so hot i cry that doesn't look
like every episode i've not actually
cried no
no
no
but that has been a thing people like
you can't do both of these things and i
think it still really frustrates people
and i was like i can and i did but that
doesn't necessarily
apply to people who have even more
struggles than i would appearing
professional where it is important
because the the yeah i get like
i i strongly agree with nobody can until
somebody does
but i still think there are caveats to
that that other people always think
there will always be caveats there will
always be exceptions there will always
be
um reasons there will always be all
sorts of things i also want to say
when talking about privilege
somebody's telling you that you have
privilege
nobody's saying that you didn't work
hard and this is like for the audience
it's a thing that i think people get
confused on a lot nobody is saying that
you didn't work hard or that you weren't
unfortunate or that your circumstances
weren't extremely difficult to to tell
somebody their privilege if they're
saying that you didn't have to work hard
very shitty person that's not what
privilege is all it really means is just
that you didn't have one particular
barrier so you didn't not get the job
because you were black
that barrier doesn't exist for you it's
not to say you didn't work really
[ __ ] hard and throw your all at
something and come from a bad place like
it and i think that that's a real
misconception is being privileged
doesn't mean you didn't have to struggle
it's just that you didn't have a
particular struggle it's just like just
recognize the fact that you didn't have
this working
i didn't have that working for me and
you didn't have this working against you
yeah that's that's a fair
it wasn't a fair playing field
um
[ __ ] we got the artist
i think can you separate i can
i have a little bit of i can i have a
little bit of trouble with michael
jackson
and i think everything else
i'm all right would be like different
things
yeah man doesn't mean it's actually a
struggle doesn't mean it's the right
thing to do i just think i can do it i'm
a judgmental prick i can't get past it
i've never been i've never been able to
the second i like to a point where i
will actively try and avoid finding out
that things i i do like have like a bad
person attached i haven't watched
i haven't watched a single thing with
robin williams since he passed
and i just it's it's i that's not
framing it in a positive way that's
interesting well
if it's the same thing it's like i can't
separate
i can't watch
fire yeah because it makes me sad it
makes me [ __ ] sad and that i don't
typically get um
that affected i want to go see paul
mccartney on friday night and and part
of the reason why was because i was like
i have the opportunity to go see a
living legend yeah and especially after
charlie watts died was like you'll never
be able to see again the stones
that was me going to see monty python
like yeah
yeah
[ __ ] go dude and it i cried three
times
there was when he did i was i have to go
but uh i wanted to share this with you
guys because i actually thought of you
um
not you austin um
i
panda surprised me for my birthday with
these tickets
and i was i was row 20
and i was 100 feet from paul mccartney
and he's one of the ones that's just
like i i want to tick that box
and because a lot of the people that i
wish that i could have seen uh have
sadly departed but
um
that man at almost 80 years old gets up
and he starts playing let it be
and i fought to just not have my phone
with the entire show two and a half
hours of just like my phone here because
i wanted to capture it all because i
want to remember it all
but one of the most beautiful moments
was not looking at the stage but
catching out of the periphery
looking around as he's saying let it be
and everybody having their phone up
with the with the torch on with the with
a little uh light
and i looked around 60 000 75 000 people
just
a sea of white lights
and i realized that everybody
had
the same thing that we [ __ ] rebuke
people for
and the same device that is used to just
vitriolic
rants of of hatred and and nastiness
became the common tool of the most
simplest expression
of someone just going i'm here i'm
celebrating and no matter what across
the divide and there were people who
were six years old and people who were
60 years old they were people of all
colors all backgrounds didn't matter
they were here to see mccartney and for
one moment one song
65 000 people were doing the same exact
thing and as much as i like to take the
piss and be cynical
i
[ __ ] cried and i put my hand up
and i got to join in and it was like for
this moment it's possible
to have community and it was just like
it was like if nothing else
that was paul mccartney like he could he
he came out he did one song and he goes
give me a second to just drink you all
in and he took a beat and just looked
and the whole crowd just [ __ ]
exploded so it was it was one of my
favorite moments of that entire
experience
was was realizing that it's possible
for us to find something and even use
something like this
to unite us instead of divide us i mean
we absolutely can we just don't most of
the time and it's a real bummer anyway
hi everyone welcome to play watch listen
i'm alana this is
a video cam right now
when you find yourself in times of
trouble
he's mother mary comes to me he's
speaking
video game actor and that's austin
wintery he's a video game composer um
it's a beautiful story troy
i
wish that we used our phones which have
the capacity to teach us a million
things for actually learning things yeah
it's hard to reckon with
thanks elon
but that's and that's fifty percent of
the comments like that's